To wander this mausoleum in Shiraz, Iran,...
...is like stepping into the holiest of light shows.
The Shah Cheragh, which roughly translates to "king of the light" in Persian,...
...is a funerary monument and mosque,...
...a beautiful holy place for thousands of Muslim worshipers.
The structure is made of multi-colored pieces of tile and glass...
...and is considered to be the third most important pilgrimage site in Iran.
Initially started around 900 A.D. as a burial site for an important Shia Muslim figure,...
...the mosque continued to be expanded and improved.
The decision to adorn the mosque with its iconic mirror ball decoration,...
...came from Queen Tash Khatun in the 14th century.
She wanted the mosque to intensify any light a thousand times over,...
...an homage to the mosque's name.
Although meant to be a holy shrine and important pilgrimage location for Shia Muslims,...
...people of any faith can marvel at the mosque's immense beauty.